I want to bring those who have wronged me
to justice and all those who have wronged
me are right here I will begin with Ser
Gregor Clegane who killed my sister's
children and then raped her with their blood
still on his hands before killing her too
there will be your champion
while Danny kind of forgot about the iron fleet
and Euron's forces can you read the cupbearer
can read better than you see I overestimated you
look the lives of four kings grand maester Cates
history of the reigns of daeron the young
dragon baelor the blessed a book every King
should read now if the war is won we should all
find time for wisdom you're a dragon be a dragon
see it Negro that's all you had to say
what if I told you that you
can't hurt the newcomers [Music]
if you'll have me
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music] is there too many of
them what are we going to do
[Music] and who has a better story
than brand the broken lord varys i
Daenerys of House Targaryen first of
my name sentence you to die dracarys
[Music]
the golden company 20,000 men horses
elephants I believe America vo Doral
heiress was mahogany on toss the Prince he
was promised will bring the dawn of Denison
while I was training to be a faceless man with
the faces I can choose imagine become someone
else speaking their voice living their
skin relevant l is it the Lord led you
come back for a reason Stannis was not the
prince was promised that someone has to be
[Music]
so for this part of the video I was gonna show off
some funny Varys coughing merchandise like phone
cases and shirts however I didn't really like
the designs that I got for them I essentially
just went on Fiverr and hired some merch
designers to make various coughing and here
they are I personally don't really like them
that much and they're kind of low quality so I
don't want to sell it I'm not really taking
this seriously anyways because I'm doing it
for the memes but if you guys actually want
some Varys coughing merch then I'll go more
high end and have an artist make a portrait of
him or something but yeah hopefully I just like
the video and I could possibly make a third
but it's full of memes for Game of Thrones